listen up people here we go here's the
plan okay we're gonna make a gaming
console right
a kentucky fried chicken console best
part it's got a built-in chicken warmer
and then i want to make a comic book
with different versions of me populate
the multiverse i want to be the voice of
gps navigation and i want my own dating
simulator
and i want mario lopez to play me in a
laughter movie
yeah i think the colonel may have
discovered a 12th
secret herb do you know what i'm saying
[Music]
hello internet welcome to film theory
yup it is film theory you did not
accidentally click on a food theory
episode i promise you're in the right
place
theorists today's episode is all about
kentucky fried chicken
heck all of today's episodes are about
game theory food theory film theory all
about
kfc yep the fast food restaurant
and no absolutely none of it is hashtag
spawn
probably should have been probably
should have tried to have gotten that
but nope
leave it on the winter crazies blaming
on quarantine brain
heck blaming on the curse of the colonel
but for our first ever
three-way collaboration across all the
theorist channels heck it's actually a
four-way collaboration because gt live's
involved too what is this oh those games
oh wow oh wow wow arrivals there are so
many characters
there's that was great right
i'm very i'm satisfied already i'm
satisfied for our first ever four-way
collaboration across
all the theorist channels i had the idea
to make it about
kfc yes what am i doing with myself it
seems
insane i get that but bear with me here
as you probably know kfc is the keeper
of one of the greatest
unsolved mysteries of our time colonel
sanders's secret recipe blend of 11
herbs and spices today kfc keeps the
recipe physically locked in a vault in
their louisville headquarters
they've hired two separate companies to
produce separate halves of the recipe so
that no one person
not even kfc's own head chef is privy to
the entire thing
naturally this level of secrecy has
piqued the curiosity of kfc fanatics
across the globe and for
decades people have been trying to do
everything they can to figure it out
people have run lab analyses on the
chickens served in kfc restaurants
they've attempted to recreate the exact
flavor at home
through meticulous trial and error
they've latched onto recipes found in
heirloom scrapbooks they've even picked
apart the brains of the late colonel
sanders's business partners but
according to kfc
no one has ever gotten it quite right
which again is kind of ironic because
the whole shtick is that no one
person knows the true recipe so do you
know it kfc do you not know it
the suspicious matpat is suspicious my
eyes narrow in your direction kfc so the
tldr here is that plenty of people have
approached this from a variety of
different scientific and analytic
angles but has anyone ever tried to
solve it from a film
angle i ask because in december kfc
released a movie
a lifetime mini movie to be more precise
it's titled
a recipe for seduction and yessiree that
is mario lopez playing the colonel
himself
harland sanders a little adorable
crouton wearing dollar store facial hair
don't call me crouton now it would be
easy to just write this thing off as
some marketing stunt
and yes it is most definitely that the
script is at times indistinguishable
from a kfc ad the chicken
is delicious bunny oh please we both
know i can't cook like this
it's my new chef he's incredibly
talented so i gotta admit not many
chicken ads i've seen in the past
feature a plot where a girl's mother is
having an affair with her daughter's
fiancee you remember our long weekend in
the vineyard how could i forget it
if you marry my daughter i promise
there'll be more long weekends in your
future
what am i watching oh it's so gross what
sort of
post-apocalyptic capitalist dystopia do
we live in
it is a kfc soap opera and here i am
sitting
and writing an episode about this oh
gosh i'm part of the problem aren't
i anyway i'm here to tell you that a
recipe for seduction might be more than
just an ironic
self-aware way to boost kfc sales much
more you see theorists i believe that
this mini movie is
absolutely saturated with hints about
the colonel's world
famous secret recipe that's right a
recipe for seduction
may also be a recipe for kfc's original
recipe and that my friends is a recipe
for a film theory so hold on to your
badly spirit gummed facial hair
theorists cause this one is gonna be
finger licking good now in order to
properly enjoy this mini movie you're
gonna have to take
everything you might know about the
real-life harland sanders the
cantankerous senior citizen who launched
the kentucky fried chicken franchise in
1952 and who one time punched a dude out
cold in court and jettison it all out
from your mind see kfc's been playing
around with the whole colonel sanders
character fast and loose in recent years
from their famous commercials in which
different actors portray the colonel to
their dc
comics collaboration in which different
versions of the kernel exist across the
multiverse to a kfc themed dating
simulator which we played on gt live
that allows people to
date the colonel and they're at it again
in a recipe for seduction
here harlan sanders is young
contemporary and likes to show off his
biceps and for as crazy as the real-life
stories of harland are
he to my knowledge did not launch his
chicken restaurant after surviving a
kidnapping and murder attempt by his
rich employer just kill him already mom
now the plot of a recipe for seduction
feels very on brand for a lifetime movie
a beautiful young woman named jessica is
being pressured to marry rich
we're weeks away from the bank
repossessing our house but it's so
unfair our family's livelihood shouldn't
depend on who i choose to marry
i'm sorry jessica marrying billy is the
only thing that can save us but instead
of falling for billy the wealthy jerk
that her mother wants her to marry
jessica instead falls in love with her
family's newly hired private chef
harlan sanders oh i'm sorry to interrupt
harland doesn't have himself a penny to
his name but he does have a secret
recipe that could one day
change the world tell me about you the
harlan sanders story
but with the author of it i'd have a
chapter in there about my secret recipe
changing the world oh a secret recipe
how mysterious so it pretty much has
everything you want in a feature-length
lifetime rom-com
campy romance over-the-top villains soap
opera level violence fried chicken
but a recipe for seduction is also super
self-aware and condensed down into a
speedy 16 minutes i'm happy to report
that it's actually a really fun watch
even for a guy like me who doesn't
usually seek out lifetime movies in fact
if you want to watch it right now the
whole thing is available
on youtube again hashtag not spawn but
if you do end up going over there and
watching it leave a comment telling them
that they should sponsor us in the
future
you don't have to pay me for these
videos but please just send me a giant
statue of harlan
sanders himself but the moment in the
movie that really got my theory juices
flowing was this
billy intent on finding a way to get the
hunky new chef out of the picture
sneaks into harlan's kitchen and finds
his secret recipe
written on a piece of paper and they
actually show it on screen for a split
second secret's out chicken man rewind
that one back pause it
there folks this is it at long last the
colonel secret recipe
is gonna be revealed to us zoom in
enhance enhance again
okay so uh that's a bit of a letdown
there is no new info on the paper it's
just
kfc teasing us but this is what i'm
talking about when i say that the mini
movie is self-aware they know that we
were all gonna pause it in that moment
they know that we're dying to find out
the secret of this recipe and just
because they didn't show us the
handwritten recipe on screen
doesn't mean that they didn't give us
something to snack on as i kept watching
i began to notice a recurring theme
see if you can spot it
for some reason there are citrus fruits
littered throughout this entire mini
movie remember its run time is only 16
minutes and yet lemons
limes and oranges make dozens of
on-screen appearances and look i get it
the movie is about a chef so we're bound
to see a number of ingredients
throughout the movie but this very
specific pairing of lemons limes and
oranges
appear across multiple scenes it was
enough to get me suspicious
sure maybe they're just there to add a
splash of color on screen but
how do you explain this harlan sanders
the new cook
harland was head chef at lipti problemos
it's an incredibly random line that
doesn't go anywhere and it's weirdly
specific in the way that it gets me to
start asking questions
you see le petite pomp le mousse
translates to the little grapefruit
yet another citrus fruit i mean they
could have picked any fancy-sounding
restaurant name they wanted they could
have tossed in a chicken reference or
a kentucky reference but they went with
grapefruit
coincidence i think not it is so
random that it can't be random friends
this can be no oversight on the part of
the filmmakers
what's the deal with all of the citrus
because surely there can be no citrus
fruits in the colonel's secret recipe
right the real life harlan sanders was
an accomplished cook and proud
southerner for him
or anyone else to put fruit into a
savory southern fried chicken recipe
would be
well it would be unusual to say the
least sure i guess fruit technically
meets the criteria to be considered
a spice since it's part of a plant
that's used to flavor food but
there's no grapefruit on any spice rack
i've ever seen
so what's the deal kfc why'd you go out
of your way to litter your own mini
movie with all these citrus references
unless there was a reason to do so so i
did some research on the topic and i
discovered that we can all rest easy
there is absolutely no reason to believe
that harlan
sanders ever included citrus fruits in
his fried chicken recipe
however the kentucky fried chicken
franchise
is a different story in fact the fine
print on their own website
explicitly states that citrus is indeed
involved more specifically citric acid
now let's hit the pause button for a
moment because this is an important
distinction to make kfc may call it
their
original recipe but the fried chicken
you served at kfc today is not identical
to the fried chicken you would have been
served at kfc in
say the 1960s see in order to keep the
food quality consistent across their
growing number of franchises kentucky
fried chicken which harlan sanders sold
in 1964
elected to streamline the processes by
which kfc's menu items were prepared
after all not every kfc employee can be
as gifted in the kitchen as the great
colonel sanders so the simpler they
could make it the better
it should also be noted that harlan
sanders was quite unhappy
and quite vocal about what he perceived
to be a slippage in quality after the
kfc franchise was sold to the new
ownership so yeah over the decades there
have been some tweaks to the colonel's
original recipe for business related
reasons
kfc claims the original 11 herbs and
spices remain
unchanged to this very day although
they've admitted other aspects of the
recipe and preparation
methods have received face lifts such as
the adoption of soybean oil as their
frying oil of choice especially in the
u.s you see in the 20th century soybean
oil wasn't yet cost effective enough to
be used by huge franchises like kfc
but in recent years soybean oil has
grown in popularity
and availability thanks to the fact that
it's low in saturated fats and contains
no
trans fats however while healthier
soybean oil does have a downside
soybeans in their natural state have a
high concentration of linolenic acid
which causes the oil to spoil much more
quickly than traditional frying oils
fortunately there are certain additives
including citric
acid that can improve soybean oil's
performance as a frying oil so that's
why kfc
now adds citric acid to its frying oil
it allows them to use a healthier oil
now most of the additives listed in the
fine print of kfc's site like tbhq
don't affect the taste of the food in
any detectable way citric acid however
has an extremely strong taste and it's
possible that the sour citrusy taste
is at least mildly detectable in the
fried chicken care to guess what citrus
fruits contain the highest concentration
of citric acid
they would be lemons and limes followed
by grapefruits and oranges
that's right the exact same four
seemingly out of place citrus fruits
that are featured throughout a recipe
for seduction
this is the real reason kfc made a mini
movie centering around the colonel's
secret recipe
they wanted to point us recipe seekers
in the right direction
many many people have attempted to
recreate kfc's original recipe over the
course of many many years but their
so-called original recipe is ever
evolving so anyone who wants to recreate
the exact taste of the fried chicken at
kfc needs to keep up with the times
citric acid is a contemporary tweak to
the recipe which is why kfc decided to
draw our attention to it using a
contemporary reimagining of the kernel
in a recipe for seduction but hey that's
just a theory is what i would normally
say at this point see
we don't run into this kind of situation
every day here on film theory but today
we don't have to speculate about this
and wait to see if it's true we can
actually run an experiment
and find out today if this was just a
theory after all
and that's exactly what steph and i are
doing over on the food theory channel in
a video
uploaded at the same time as this one
we've taken this theory
along with some of the most legit kfc
original recipe recreation attempts
out there and we're answering the
question once and for all what
is kfc's secret recipe what's the blend
of spices
is the inclusion of citric acid the
missing puzzle piece that's kept us from
matching the taste of kfc's fried
chicken exactly
spoiler alert i think we found ourself a
solution
it didn't make sense to do it over here
so head on over to food theory
right now to see what it takes to crack
the code that episode is up right now so
click the video that you see on screen
or the link in the top line in the
description to check it out and once
you've done that
head on over to game theory where we are
also talking about kfc
and their next generation gaming system
no joke that has itself
a chamber to keep your chicken warm
which the biggest shocker of all
is not as dumb as you think so if you
want to follow the natural viewing loop
i'd suggest heading over to food theory
next where we have part two to this
episode that you just watched then
continue over to game theory where we
just posted the episode about how kfc
just won the console wars oh yeah and
also before you go
just consider subscribing help make this
the year when film theory crosses the 10
million subscriber mark so get on it
guys you've got yourself a ton of kfc
content to fill up on but as always
remember
they're all just theories and this one
was a film
theory and don't call me crouton